Hey guys, how's it going it's Justine back with another unboxing and today
This is something that I'm really excited about I have had my eye on this for quite a while and finally
I was like okay. I'm buying it
I need this in my life mostly because the cameras that I use are Sony other than the rx100 which has a flip up screen
These have a flip up but like not flip to the side
This is my higher-end vlogging camera, and then the a7s2 which I'm using right here
They all have these screens that do not flip out those one of the things that I absolutely loved about Canon don't love just being
Able to flip that screen to the side really quickly see everything that I need to see if for whatever reason Sony
Is just so opposed to that so hopefully in the next line of cameras that they come out with they will take us vloggers into
Consideration my friend Nick has been shooting a bunch of my cooking videos for me recently he also shot a lot of the iPhone 10
cinematic shots that you guys probably saw in all of my iPhone 10 videos so with that he was using the Panasonic gh5
And this camera has two SD card and you can record for just however long you want to unlike the Sony's which end up
Overheating if you have them on longer than an hour, and they start recording your shooting in 4k after about thirty minutes
I do feel like there's a lot of things that Sony needs to address
But with all that being said I am by far the biggest fan of Sony ever which is why I'm unboxing this today
Which I haven't even told you what I'm unboxing. This is that you focus Sony bundle
This is by small HD so what this is is a 5-inch small HD screen
It's a touchscreen and this is the focus bundle so it comes with this arm right here
So you could attach to the screen you could attach a mic it also comes with a battery
Charger looks like a micro HD camera. I guess. I'll just find out why don't I just open it and stop talking?
I've been waiting so long I was like do I buy this do I not buy this I don't really need
Need it because matt has one so I've been borrowing his smaller one, but then he needed it back so I said okay
I guess this is my time
It looks so good, holy moly
God why is this smell this smells like the lawn and garden center of Walmart?
So this does a micro-hdmi in which is fine?
I just hope that it comes with one of those cables because I don't have one. Oh it comes with a little glass face
Oh, this is good because I'd like to protect my screen because I do not trust myself. Okay, nothing else in there
What have we got in here, ooh
All of our accessories okay, so it looks like it does come with an HDMI cable which is very great news
Oh
Wow so I'm assuming that I can still use some of the other batteries that I use I have so many extra Canon batteries
So I usually do use those on the back of this
but this thing is as heavy as my camera and it also stinks with this battery I
Have use this camera here is our
HDMI cables looks like it comes with a regular one a micro in a minute. So this looks like it has a HDMI adapter
here's the issue the
Microphone that I use is a hot shoe mic so if I use this I'm now gonna have to use a different microphone
And it's not really that big of a deal because it gives us all these little extras
So I'm able to easily mount a microphone over here if I would like to there's a little
Hole that you have to match up to on the side of this into here
So it'll go a little bit tighter got myself a another
Microphone here, so this can just go right here on the side
It gives you some extra little adapters, so you can just attach these to the side if you'd like
You guys are getting the first view I don't even know what it looks like but wow this looks
So silly oh, it's so crazy that it's a touchscreen
Yeah, guys. This is the future right here so the tripod that I usually use I am a vlogger now
Bring that battery it is so insane like I can't believe it
This will be so great when I travel because I don't like to bring a huge crazy setup like I have right here
But this will all kind of condensed down very easily to be able to pack it
I did order this monitor through bnh, which I absolutely love not sponsored. I bought this just a full disclosure
I guess whatever deal B&H was running it gave you a small HD case with it, too
So I have like this nice little Pelican case for it. This is so heavy
Well what am I doing, but while this screen looks so good?
I've got to get that cover on there before this thing gets destroyed
So I've definitely gonna mess around with this because I feel like this isn't the ideal setup
I don't like where this microphone placement is there's got to be something else that I can do and maybe if I can even get
Like a smaller microphone. I could get something hmm. Well. Thank you guys for watching
I hope that you enjoyed this random unboxing of my small HD screen
This is the small HD focus again if you guys are interested
I'll put a link in the description
Leave me some comments below and let me know if you guys think this is realistic because it's not realistic am I crazy
It doesn't really even matter so you know if you would carry this around in public
I'm not even sure if I can bring myself to do that, but we'll see I'll see you guys in my next video